yeah what's up
oh that's easy Iranian oh right
Israeli oh oh right okay I got it now
Sardinian hello everyone welcome to the
Laing focused Channel and my name is
Paul today's topic is the Italian
language Italian may not get as much
attention as French Spanish and
Portuguese because it's mainly spoken in
Europe rather than in former colonies
but it's still one of the most widely
spoken languages in the European Union
with around 68 million speakers they're
around 60 million of those speakers are
in Italy of course where Italian is the
official language Italian is also the
official language of San Marino a tiny
enclaves surrounded by Italy and it's
also a de facto official language of the
Vatican City it's also one of the four
official languages of Switzerland where
it's mainly used in Ticino and the
southern canton of called London and
it's official at the regional level in
Slovenian Astoria and in istria county
in Croatia it's also spoken by overseas
communities among them in the United
States where over 700,000 people speak
it according to the US Census Bureau and
Italian has had a cultural impact on the
rest of the world because Italian
composer's developed our current system
of musical notation Italian is the
common language of musical notation and
nomenclature words like acapella
crescendo soprano and tempo all come
from Italian and if you're a coffee
lover you probably know some Italian
words because Italian coffee culture has
inspired imitation throughout the world
words like espresso from cafe espresso
meaning pressed out coffee grande which
means large venti which means 20 as in
more than 20 ounces of coffee and
treinta which means heart attack
actually it means 30 but yeah Italian is
a member of the Italo Dalmatian branch
of the Romance language family but when
we talk about the Italian language what
exactly are we talking about as I spoke
about at length in my
Oh on the languages of Italy Italy has
historically had an extremely diverse
variety of romance dialects which can be
grouped together and arguably classified
as dialects of various regional
languages the majority of these dialects
belong to the Italo Dalmatian branch but
many in northern Italy do not when we
speak about the Italian language in its
strictest sense we are speaking about
standard Italian which developed from a
specific set of Italo Dalmatian dialects
dos Cano the Tuscan dialects that are
spoken in the tuscany region and in
particular the florentine dialect of
florence the romance dialects in italy
like all Romance languages developed
from varieties of vulgar latin latin
originally the language of Rome and the
Roman Empire remained the formal
language of writing and literature up
until the late Middle Ages in what is
now Italy but during that period a
vernacular literary tradition began to
emerge in other words literature written
in the language of everyday speech
rather than Latin became more widespread
the seeds of standard Italian were
planted by Tuscan poetry and literature
in the 13th century in the 14th century
Tuscan poet Dante Alighieri published
his masterpiece the Divine Comedy in
Italian originally called just comedia
but later referred to as Divina Commedia
Dante was from Florence and his writing
largely resembled the Tuscan dialect of
that city with some elements of Latin as
well as other dialects Dante is often
referred to as the father of the Italian
language because his work came to be
read by educated people in every region
of the peninsula as a result the form of
language used in his writing became the
most widely understood and over the next
couple of centuries it became
established as the de facto standard
literary language other 14th century
poets who greatly contributed to this
were Francesco Petrarca
and Giovanni Boccaccio in the 16th
century Pietro Benbow helped to
standardize literary Italian based on
the model of Petrarca Boccaccio and
allegory later in the 19th century a
novelist named Alessandro Manzoni
had a big impact on the development of
modern Standard Italian thanks to his
novel the betrothed witch
is called Ypres mrs. palsey in Italian
this was the first novel written in
Italian and is said to be the most
famous novel in the Italian language
even though it's not widely read in
other languages Manzoni wrote the novel
in the modern Florentine dialect with
some influence from the Florentine
literature of the 14th century when the
historical states of Italy became
unified in the 19th century Italian
became the official language of Italy
and the Italian government accepted
Manzo knees proposal to make this
variety standard Italian at the time of
unification most Italians were not able
to speak Italian
meaning literary Tuscan different
estimates from that time range from 2.5
percent of the population to 10 percent
of the population even though it was the
most widely understood written language
most of the population were illiterate
and lacked exposure to it unifying the
linguistically diverse nation became one
of italians main functions nowadays
virtually all Italians are fluent in
Italian which exists alongside Italy's
vast array of romance dialects though in
some areas Italian has largely replaced
local dialect what's Italian like first
let's look at a few basic words and
phrases hello ciao notice the letter C
here represents the soft sound that's
how it's pronounced before I or II
before a Oh or you it represents a hard
sound as in quanto Costa which means how
much does it cost
good morning Buon Giorno notice here
that the letter G represents a soft
sound again that's the pronunciation
before I or II before a oh you or a
consonant it's pronounced gah
like in the word for thank you gasps
yeah aside from the hard G notice the
pronunciation of the letter Z in Italian
it represents a sound or at the
beginning of words though there are
exceptions goodbye
arrivederci or ciao note the
pronunciation of the Italian R sound
it's a rolled R sound in other words a
trill it's a longer trill sound when
doubled and it's a tap when it appears
between vowels you'll notice it in the
next couple of words as well
please bit of
I'd like Buddha I'd like the fish please
very delicious therefore water notice
the pronunciation of SC in baseship it's
pronounced like sure before I and II but
before other vowels or before consonants
it's pronounced scut like in the phrase
meaning excuse me miss scusi on top of
the sky sound notice that s is
pronounced Z between vowels
it's voiced where is the station no they
lost at SUNY recall that the letter Z
sounds like sir not Z I love Italy Amol
Italia I understand
capisco I don't understand non capisco
now let's jump into some more sentences
and see what we can learn about the
language marco parla Italiano english
this means mark speaks english and
italian word for word it Marco speaks
Italian and English in simple sentences
like this the word order is the same as
in English another thing you might
notice and you may have noticed in the
previous set of basic words and phrases
is the strong tendency for Italian words
to end in a vowel that's true for almost
all words in Italian they end in vowels
we saw two exceptions in the previous
set of basic words Ile meaning da and no
no meaning no or not both of them short
function words there are five vowel
letters in Italian ah ay ay e oo o mmm
two of them E and O have two sounds open
and closed it's worth noting that
different regional accents don't always
distinguish between the open and closed
vowel sounds so if you can't it's not
the end of the world I guess there are
also dipped on though they are usually
just a simple combination of two vowels
another thing to notice is that each of
the words with more than one syllable is
stressed on the penultimate syllable in
other words the second to last syllable
Marco parla Italiano
English this isn't true for all words in
Italian but it's generally the case the
verb
Bala is the third person singular
conjugation of the verb para la in the
present tense Italian has three classes
of verbs are verbs
err err verbs and ei verbs notice that
the three classes are conjugated
slightly differently with some slightly
different verb endings other verbs are
almost all regular but among err a and E
reverbs there's a significant number of
irregular verbs that veer from the
regular patterns let's look at another
sentence oh man Giotto in your cheapo
periphery topper pranzo gee lasagna
it means I ate my favourite food for
lunch today lasagne word-for-word it
I have eaten the my food favorite for
lunch today lasagna I guess I didn't
really need to translate lasagna in this
sentence the syntax is a little
different from English unlike the
previous sentence first of all the
subject pronoun can be dropped because
the person and number are clear from the
conjugation of the verb Oh is the first
person singular present tense form of
the verb
Avira which means to have here it's
functioning as the auxiliary verb for
man giotto this is the tense passat
o'brosey mou equivalent to the present
perfect tense in English but in Italian
it's also generally used where we would
use the simple past in English this is
one of 14 tenses in Italian though there
are 21 if we include the imperative
present and past infinitives present and
past participles and present and past
gerunds some of those tenses are simple
tenses and others are compound tenses
formed from an auxiliary verb plus the
past participle of the main verb or the
body gpo bus Sato for most verbs
compound tenses are formed with the
auxiliary verb avere though there is a
subset of verbs that take s city meaning
to be instead these are usually
intransitive verbs that describe
movement or a state or condition let's
look at the phrase il mio Cibo mio is a
possessive adjective like my in English
the possessive adjectives as well as
other adjectives like prefer Ito
agree with the gender and number of the
noun nouns ending in O are usually
masculine like Tchibo and nouns ending
in a are usually feminine like torta
meaning cake some nouns end in E and
these can be either masculine or
feminine
for instance panty meaning bread is mass
given while Karen a meaning meat is
feminine in Italian possessive
adjectives are preceded by a definite
article like neo Chivo
la mia torta mei biscotti lemmya
rejected notice that there are different
definite articles that agree with gender
and number masculine and feminine
singular and masculine and feminine
plural there are actually a couple more
that appear in certain phonetic contexts
low masculine singular before s plus
another consonant or before Z look l '
both masculine and feminine singular
before vowels and masculine plural
before vowels before s plus another
consonant or the consonant Z or before
GN so there's L Cibo lewd zucchero
la niñas la torta EB Scott the learjet
de Jean Yawkey notice that the
adjectives prefer Ito comes after the
noun whereas an English it comes before
it in Italian functional adjectives like
possessive adjectives and numbers come
before the noun descriptive adjectives
normally come after the now but they
sometimes come before it
the general rule is that adjectives that
are strictly factual come after the now
these are called denoted adjectives for
example la torta fresca the fresh cake
fresh is denoted it's factual adjectives
that are connotative in other words they
imply something about the noun come
before
for example la deliciosa torta the
delicious cake some adjectives can come
before or after but with a difference in
meaning for example wawapo vero means
the poor man he's factually poor while
in Barbara warm means the miserable man
a couple of notes about pronunciation
and orthography Oh
note that the letter H is silent in
Italian in the phrase y'know we see two
different consonant sounds that are
written with G plus another consonant
letter G L represents the sound Lea this
is one of the trickier sounds for
learners of Italian it's kind of like
the double L sound in the word million
but not quite G n represents the sound
a palatal nasal something like yeah but
not quite
also note the CH in Miyake and also in
zucchero CH is always pronounced as a
hard sound in Italian similarly G H is
always pronounced as a hard sound
puggy d Mundi another sentence lays
Tendo Sanibel Amanita this means you're
wearing a nice shirt work forward it's
you stay wearing aa nice shirt this
sentence could also mean she is wearing
a nice shirt this is a polite sentence
and in polite speech third-person
pronouns and conjugations are used for
the second person lait is the third
person feminine singular subject pronoun
and lay with a capital L is the polite
second person singular but lay would be
capitalized here anyway since it's at
the beginning of the sentence so out of
context the sentence is ambiguous but
not in context Stein dose and O is a
present continuous construction it uses
the verb study as the auxiliary verb and
the gerund of the main verb here the
verb is endo sorry because this is a
polite sentence study is in its third
person singular conjugation stop rather
than second person singular notice also
the indefinite article here indefinite
articles agree with the gender of the
noun
una is the feminine indefinite article
and it agrees with the feminine noun
Murrieta though before vowels the
feminine article is une with an
apostrophe
una Inca the masculine definite article
is una as in une Capello though it's una
before Z or s with another consonant uno
studio there are no plural indefinite
articles but partitive articles meaning
some or any are used instead positive
articles combine deep meaning of with a
definite article as we saw before this
adjective here also agrees with the noun
and gender as well as in number then la
is the feminine singular form it comes
before the noun because it's connotative
it's not factual
but implies something subjective about
the shirt Italian is a beautiful
language and one that captures the
imagination of people all over the world
because of the huge Italian cultural
influence both historical and
contemporary I guess that's why Italian
is the fourth most widely studied
language in the world some sources say
5th but let's go with 4th the question
of the day for native speakers of
Italian what other features of Italian
do you want others to know about and for
learners of Italian what have you found
the most fun or interesting about the
language if you enjoyed this video then
check out Lange focus on the various
social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram Twitter and of course YouTube
and as always I want to give a very
special thanks to my patrons on patreon
especially my top 2 your patrons whose
names are right here on the screen many
extra special thanks to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]
you
[Music]